yes at the moment my daily work is
changing
tank containers ran that chose right now
more open raining earlier this week less
teaching weeks and transform into
coffee that soul and is the sector blog
cargill got into my head or something
well we have generalized jews
disclaimer still need a coffee party
what now weekend seldom all those
elective anonymous surgery and you're
using the two other person for
accommodations
zoë respect torn in the neck always
and we hope that the surgeon at which the
intensity of
lombardy yes problem nine to change the
high number lee  and his en city that
the psychedelic reach the yes and that
theory haran more countries was merely a
willy kit
work hard the healthcare system wo
n't sing me like this if a new song
prolapse and the voice cast for the
nests and 15 this one is here  in words a
decision change completely
highlighter in with a modem and mieke
but
working very hard we donate the extra is
force an order to increase our eyes
capa  city ​​and hospital capacity and
weeding or such a hype and the sionie
becomes in the lodge in order to grace' and
at live id for pigeons and you're not
sure that will be in af will my
suggesting that you get prepare the
seasons sick  and that i was the once you
start measurements seriously isolation
she is probably eating tool for social
desing isolation and logged out
why because now we make the girls at
sign up just like at boys complete
block yard what you cd and don't expect a
huge  effect for you about an asmr einer terneuzen
how you yes how you all hope that will see
those defects in resources become one
week try and this what the next
week i will not be
f perfect at the the lockdown die chose
this one at the nursery  right on that
choose and the special love ship your
case is will this is
and investment' for a future for the
second half of march and this is
essential
otherwise you collapse what the next few
days will not be effected it all what the
lockdown implem  ented a few days ago
so what we normally hissed from the epidemiology
and
en lockdown qualif or two for the hours
of work and have huge consequences and
tufts in this leather and marco between
back out of the people you're seeing
coming into my see you  there ah embryos
a total aomori sort of the yo
guys you je nou je is so that for my
people or old and they would experience'
and sort on my the clinic competitions
like cissé because curse
what attraction me to leave and
people old rebellions
this would  be much more severe requiring
oxygen therapy and diy red specific
therapy and as a specialization and for a
large part of the passions
the severity and reach and not for in
the truck greenkey pension and mechanical
ventilation for my idea so again
treating box cases and this most and
lam johnny
indian you alone ratios ever and my
idea how ventilation and mechanical
ventilation knucklebones the restorers
video first animal is reversible
body take some other  resources te and time the
ladder
in order to proof how is that some of you
staphon de bar crusaders yes from the
landlady website want i want you
silent again opening git log in you're just a
meeting na de force patients and dimes
in the  culinary
the more who wants more i working' work
hard not double dutch ships and soon
after ten days there already
almost all of a square drag the private de
and just as problem microspheres can
annemarie come
the reason there is a driver gable too
big for  one or two months
so far weekend and it's a jans and
marks when we new look at your
european and then the standing metrics by
death was happening the underground in the
hospital in this city in the race and the
you working in
fashionable youtube other countries around
the world
yes second countries a heavily contact
with colleagues within could my media
media flash and colleagues about the words
in the burden for foundation and a train
to spread words deathfest
confess something  ik get free for this is
possible the pass the unique way to
present preventive health care system
for luxe is to enforce en love paulus is
possible to grace'
your eyes you capacité en your
hospitalisatie
capacité en toe toe
je simulation and to train in a
using  gps staff the perfect the chicken
with the die position krucio nico do you say
of all the fuss christmas off get sick in the
first few weeks
then you will not have any way be able
to take care of the passion ja om de
alma marceau have a view on  your
colleagues the healthcare professionals
in or your eyes are dragged noses
slater pride of your holding a and mentor
of sofie in fact i buy this watch your
self
yes we have couple the police
bullying positive last week
so who got there and then negative
narrower  forklift truck it might ask us heit
and half colleagues in the race us in
lombardy je word ik meer over when
my passions te
it reviews to be tests in the if i want
cheese and tomato i can the chosen to
continue to infect 3 passions and
working with the aspects impact the
colic
i was the workforce family scarves and
isolation cut
mountain specialize dust bath creations and
doctors and boat and nurses nurses and the
regions this
epidemic and december josh
yes and so finally mark i know you  and
your focusing on 20 span the passengers
target oriented king tiger award
de zj add your region haesaert access
composites drone and their gates it's
the hollows fingers in places of
you can other countries
carlion and not sure that all regions die
not al die may be  able to de cms
lombardy
lambert is one of which shows en de
Witte de lodges de leading teaching
hospital and the harm
no no xtraordinary forts en dan seek
ik have je vantage op having them some
time so he was so we will
video porcini key to learn  van damage
your sharing information very quickly
white police web daily web in arcen en
networks to share information
hoe je broad mee extra reinf  orce
the positions in another student
situation was for all and he hoped the
old grunge knew reach and the product
becomes their have and nine sides of white
lessons efficient and students and us so
flexibility you to create networks and
collaborate with weekends to work in
a boring  louis wie not uit to work in
a network
zoey have responsibility for all the
passions
not only for the passions the weather is not
in our specific als middle market is
finally we nu started of discreating
garni am i get you ever expect to be in
the situation raina  and mamboberry from
via prepared for a very well by which
here's one more whole pizzeria san finest
and or that's my name the lockdown and je
margins ii-sparta wages about feelings' and
solidarity and strict channel of people
and characters eh oui oui oui discover
and be realized hot but try your
iridium this and white eager the last
month a time prepared to treat the box of
passions that was then his respirator
videos and this  is my this shampoo
but for the news barry was
prepared to treat for many patients at
the same time is warm president it for
as
yes marco thank you so much for taking
the time joshua jules speak the very
best and then also typical oil company
play little pressure
do you think